what's happening Magna sites I moccasin
we're gonna watch the honest trailer for
Justice League
today it's about time they bash on
Justice League huh you're number one
movie of 2017 I really did like it I
really did enjoy the hell out of it but
hey I'm sure an honest trailer will be
really funny considering they did not
really care for it oh by the way patient
of the day shout-out today for Jay Jay
[Music]
somewhere between the awful Suicide
Squad and the excellent Wonder Woman a
new DC movie we'll get it sorted down
the middle driving the best comic book
characters ever unite for a film it's
just okay you blew it again Justice
League in the best of a production beset
by tragedy Warner Brothers bravely
forged ahead
so executives could keep their bonuses
mixing Zack Snyder's trait more glue
with the optimism of trust in there and
the priorities of great writers
production company who gorgeous that
results in its own signature blend of
orange lots and lots of orange yeah
release the Snyder crack also Minos the
Snyder cut wasn't it made of bad boy by
Green right before your eyes where the
CGI steals the CGI boxes from their CGI
hiding places you guided a CGI hero beat
CG on fight illness in MPI battlefield
until the season annuals merges with the
CGI bomb while the CGI villain it's
punched in the mouth by the hero with a
mouth made out of CGI that just looks
wrong can't really tell a bunch of sad
lose occasion be left alone if you stay
up here brooding reprocessing
the tribes of men I mean thanks who
occasionally make jokes now the staff
ski there's wonderful the traditional
hero turned into girl hung up on her ex
[Laughter]
bro sided key cyborg
who's there oh yeah spider-man goes by
the fly Superman is so distracting poor
Henry Cavill worked out for months for
this role but all I can look at this
good fake baby mouth they really
couldn't just shave his mustache or grow
a beard or you know delay the movie you
may not be that tough well that smart
you're dying or that careful with his
secret identity
just like in fact you're mine first why
is it Batman as the bad thing but wait
there's no bud that's a shame it was the
best part of the last one of Steppenwolf
DC scariest horn helmeted minor Godzilla
with the giant bladed weapon since the
movie right before with this look a
generic motivation he only to conquer a
super generic dialogue
[Music]
the ends of one but no character since
buster bluth has ever been this much of
a mother lover from under me
I also possibility ripped off everything
from The Avengers except the good
villains
come on Joss it's not stealing if you do
it from yourself after all the intricate
plotting of Batman V Superman check out
a sequel that says whoops never mind
pretending Katmandu Clark Kent for more
than 50 minutes to make Superman before
he died and when it is of course I think
it's all because he's gone and
pretending that bizarre flash nightmares
he was never that was clearly meant for
when this movie was going to be a
two-parter right so where the adventure
is felt like and at the beginning that
gives you experience DC's big team up
movie that just kind of feels like the
end where the empty our monster our
united all their biggest superheroes and
tried everything they could to make it
look like they still cared you know you
can't do this forever
I can barely do it it's a shame too
they were just starting to take some
real steps toward heroism save one save
one person okay baby steps while water
to boil sponge to run a laser pointer
okay Jason wanna The Dark Knight ow
happy ceu Hunger Games champion a super
sight I'd the voice of Warner Brothers
we might never thought this through oh I
mean dead Smash Mouth spider car spider
guard does whatever a spider car does
miles Dyson when we learn white pins
spirit worker and they recatch loser hey
there for a glass of baby month
oh and non-story through those eyes it's
our area
consumed by water cyborg it's a human
and letterman jacket the I didn't think
you were real see didn't think you
realize useful so I'm fighting you take
it talking to a car you should probably
move from flash by the aperitivo cyborg
is a human playing football the original
hand pilot in sequence
Bruce looking at holographic Superman
Barry where he was Alfred talking to a
mysterious visitor who's sending to come
hey Lois and Clark discussing their
engagement I'll take that as a yes
Warner Brothers presents Joss Whedon
Zack Snyder's Justice League part 1 of 1
so everyone in this movie have super
smelling dude my ever just got nailed
Elon Musk will create sky that sweet
dreams are made of cheese they'd like to
disagree I jeder the world and the feta
cheese everybody's looking for stove
hood whatever guys the movies still a
total blast in my mind I still have a
great time when I watch that film I
think it's one hell of a Saturday
morning cartoon the thing I can really
get on board with the most how
lackluster Batman is in this film yeah
especially when he was the best part of
BVS and then in this film I don't know
Ben Affleck just really seemed like he
didn't give a [ __ ] especially during the
scenes or he could tell it's a reshoot
Rashad's where he's like super bloated
surprised you didn't point that out he
is an obvious reshoot
yeah as I was waiting the whole chatter
for like where's all the software they
make fun of all the scenes that were not
in the tree
I didn't realize just how many of them
really there's so much yeah oh no that's
why people want a slider cut because
there are so many scenes that are not
included in here and it seems like they
just trimmed down certain scenes because
when you look at that one scene where
they're talking about the engagement
ring like that scene is kind of it moved
it up or something yeah I'm feeling all
right it's good to be back and we're
back on the fly
I just can't notice his baby face that
everyone keeps pointing out I just don't
I don't see it I don't know why not I
feel like I'm stupid about them but I
just can't notice it that particular
close-up shot is one of the better ones
because it is like a direct close up on
his face but yeah at least for me
watching it there were a couple of
scenes brought like oh your mouth
doesn't look like a real person's mouth
and they also talked about cyborg as if
he's not anything in the movie but he
was one of the standouts yeah I mean
flash is like the Peter Parker of this
cyborg here III didn't think he was like
irrelevant or useless it was just there
I thought he I thought he was one of the
better parts of the film yeah he's one
of the characters that was actually kind
of on pitch for me who I didn't mind
meeting in this movie I love that line
or whatever they say about Wonder Woman
Oh God taking like a three-dimensional
hero and make her hung up on her ex yeah
that is something I always forgot about
it when the movie was done but every
time I saw the film like it's been
decades
you gotta move that at some point the
first human dude you've met here we
could talk forever about how a terrible
Steppenwolf was yeah a Steppenwolf was
pretty awful yes the huge abundance of
CGI that that that sequence where he's
just talking about like watching a CGI
villain with a big sword still CGI
baktun from a CGI stronghold that mcgi
fight and that practical effects John
practical effects aren't worth it hey
man that arguably all that CG enhances
the cartoony scene that the movie gets
by us exactly thanks for defending my
point and I do not think I'll be curious
to see the thing about this is I'll be
curious to see a Snider cut see like
what things were supposed to look like
cuz like that whole red ending be
curious to see what that looked like as
a blue ending you know they point this
is the darker Schneider version of it
yeah Joss Whedon came in to lighten
things up fixed Zack Snyder's glue but
Joss Whedon I'm one of my favorite parts
of this when they point out how this is
takes place right after BVS yeah there's
so much inconsistency with how the
Justice League is playing out which
obviously came in the terms of reshoots
and rewrites after the response to be vs
Superman you know the world's falling
apart because Superman's dead when he vs
everyone seem to hate Superman movies
seems like life sucks if you're sure man
no one likes you know what's happier
around if you're not happy Bruce never
had a moment of real conversation with
Clark still if Bruce was only focused on
getting back Superman to defeat
Steppenwolf that would have been one
thing but there are scenes of a team
who's never met Clark needs those
elements I don't remember him being
bested through car it can be it's just
because I think the plot needs it too
and this other thing with the
time-travel sequence flash of BBS which
is clearly meant for the Justice League
movie that just gets completely ignored
yeah even looks I mean they change the
design and everything
yeah because flash here in the BBS scene
he has like long hair it looks like
they've been in war for awhile or
something like that almost looks like
he's got some stubble going on or
something or maybe in Justice League Lee
prevented it from happening and that's
why none of this had to take place
because Lois was the key to getting
Superman there you go cousin VVS he has
a dream sequence where Superman's gone
bad and then he's killing people and
he's about to kill Batman and then flash
shows up saying Lois is the key so maybe
because they got Louis to get Superman
to be good guy and they prevented all
this from happening I got to think
things through
yeah justify I think that's just by the
Justice they wanted eventually we'll try
and go back and make a prequel movie
explaining just this one seems well
screen junkies thanks for making this
this was some really funny [ __ ] right
here page from the day shout for JT JT
the man from Hawaii as we like to call
the guy I think that you could be part
of the
Justice League my friends definitely you
could be the Asian addition that the
Justice League really needs you could be
the first big Asian superhero what
chadwick boseman has set the bar for for
black superheroes and movies you could
set the bar for Asians and that could be
DC's new think think about it DC gets
Wonder Woman Marvel gets Black Panther
then you could be the Asian guy I'm
thinking an Asian Lobo I think you could
be in Michael Bay's Lobo and be the next
big Asian comic-book character oh yeah
because you're such a loudmouth you know
always making the irreverent jokes yeah
Don cigars and whatnot not giving a F
you're not quiet just listening to us
ramble during the Google Hangouts you
just don't shut up that is who Lobo is
don't change don't ever change man keep
that motor mouth running because that's
what you do best my friend and also how
are the girls in Hawaii man you must get
so many girls girls don't know why I
imagine are all fit and beautiful and
dark-skinned and laid-back yeah ello
covered in suntan lotion at all times
and doing this all the time yeah just
always in a perpetual actually quite
painful never stop stop you got to
subscribe the real rejects click that
notification bell catch on the
flippety-flip